he's shawn merriman a former NFL
linebacker and working with MMA's
bellator joining us here in studio we'll
talk about that coming up in a moment do
you have a sporting event that would
rival what happened last night no last
night was pretty incredible yeah yeahs
was up there have you ever gotten to the
point where you're sort of out of your
body experience where a moment overtakes
you where you can't just be yourself uh
yeah probably some of the big playoff
games I played into you know you hit a
crowd and you know it's not really one
or two people you hear hear like a big
wave and it just saw almost it seem like
you're not there like you're in some
type of a movie so I've had that feeling
before I just brought up brian baldinger
of the NFL network yeah and he got
suspended for six months now he's
talking about Ezekiel Elliott I talks
about bounty use the word bounty which
that's a no-no he says that he doesn't
like Ezekiel Elliott ooh this is a guy
that you that we've got to hurt this is
a guy that we've got to take out of the
game he talked about that he doesn't
like rookies these guys would come in
folder themselves he had the belly shirt
at the draft why did he get suspended
for six months because he was at the NFL
network that's the only that's the only
reason um if he didn't use bounty if you
do said look I don't like this kid I you
know I don't like punks yeah but you
know even the word bounty um well first
of all I've had the privilege of working
with Brian balding for quite some time
and I think he's a great guy love
working with him love being around him
but he's old school he's very old school
so those words in a way he's speaking is
how they would speak back then in the
locker room or in a meeting room when he
played I don't think he intentionally
mean to go out there and say I want to
hurt this guy and break his knee or ACL
or do something to jeopardize his career
but back when brian played that's what
guys would do you know as far as going
out in targeting a guy like hate not
talking to hurt him but we want to make
sure this guy knows that we don't like
him or we want to make sure that he
knows it not one person is going to hit
him every play but if he wasn't that NFL
Network he
would have been no way in the world he
wouldn't have got suspended for six
months which is you know insane okay but
did you guys target players without you
know whether there was a bounty or was
there incentives you know you're playing
it's a big game you know you're playing
Tom Brady yeah do you even have to say
hey let's make sure we put a helmet on
him every single play we can yeah we we
should say it all the time but not the
intent to hurt that was that was a
difference was there an incentive though
if you got a clean hit and he knocked
out Brady no just a pat on the back but
that was good enough for us because we
pointed guys out who were dirty players
who would hit you after the whistle guys
will come to the sideline talk trash
during the game we wanted to make sure
we get those guys when I mean get not to
hurt him you know hurt his career but
make sure that make sure he knew that he
couldn't do that and it wasn't it wasn't
going to work with us do you think that
defensive players look at Cam Newton
differently or want to tackle him
differently because of the Superman
thing the way he celebrated does that
factor in it all absolutely um and you
know guys that especially in his case
when they're winning is its dancing it's
fun everything's happy I and when he's
losing it's the opposite I don't think
the cam newton is hit any more than he
was this year and he was last year the
fact is they're not winning and
nothing's fun when you're not winning
Sinell but you have to hit him
differently don't you than any other
quarterback know you want to get all
quarterbacks to the ground don't get me
wrong but cam newton 10 yeah Cam Newton
is a different kind of player you know
he can probably run over half of your
defense so yeah you a little bit more I
guess aggressive well you can't be more
aggressive to it to a guy that uh that
is much bigger than probably you know
half of your defenders but you go to his
knees no not go there's knees but you
were trying to get him down a
quarterback or someone who is 180 pounds
or 190 pounds you would almost have to
go for its legs because if you didn't go
for his legs yet one person of that size
is not bringing him down so you they
would literally tell you hey you can't
run without your legs that doesn't mean
a kind of take your helmet to his knee
but bring him down by his legs he can't
run without using them you see a crybaby
he's right now he's
whining way too much and you know I
think cam is a great person the problem
is is that he's not going to get the
treatment that other big quarterbacks in
the National Football League is getting
for several reasons for one he's not
he's not normal you know he's not a guy
that you can let up on and kind of just
bring him down like a normal quarterback
for two he's been complaining about
every single time he's been hitting it
pretty appropriately and when he was
talking about going to call Roger
Goodell you know that's something he
should've did before and if the NFL
doesn't do anything about it then you
starting to complain and make it a
little bit more public situation see
Sean I think he made a mistake going
public with it oh absolutely because you
down hey I'm gonna go to the
commissioner I'm tattling on all of you
guys here right and it felt like hey
keep it in-house you notice how we play
the game if somebody wants to back
channel here great but all of a sudden
you get an audience with the Pope then
it's different yeah you know what he has
that cloud he's Cam Newton he's a you
know a huge name of the National
Football League he can call Roger
Goodell and say hey you know can you do
something for me Norman wanted to call
the commissioner and say I want to
complain about how I'm efficient like at
what point does the commissioners say I
can't take any calls from everybody in
the league no he he will take cam
newton's he'll probably take Josh
Norman's he will but you'll even like
josh Josh Norman's case he's complaining
about a you know a hand to the face a
penalty Cam Newton is complaining about
him possibly you know Terran is neon or
getting injured too you'll hurt his
career it's two completely different
situations I got some numbers here for
Shawne Merriman first 42 games your
career you know how many sang she had no
39 and a half it's pretty good this is a
Reggie White had more Aldon Smith and
Derrick Thomas the only guys to have
more through the first 42 games best
pass-rusher ever in your opinion is who
uh Lawrence Taylor yeah you know Lord
because you know he fought for me and
watching Lawrence Taylor play he
in in kind of invented a position that
may guys like me possible he was like
one of the first that can do almost
everything you can look at Reggie White
and some of these other guys who
outstanding who a great pass rush in
their own right but they couldn't do the
things that Lauren telleth Laura Stella
could bring to the game how many sacks
did you end up with here in your career
maybe 40 something i don't know i don't
toughest guy to bring down ah got Ben
Roethlisberger what is it he invites you
to hit him right I mean but he doesn't
go down it's a key but but cam cam and
better similar in size yeah and and I
don't hear bet I don't know just been
wine crime on getting hit no I've never
heard been complaining and that's the
difference and what's it like hitting
Roethlisberger well you think he's going
down and on his way down to go to his
knees he's thrown at 30 or 40 yards down
the field and you know he's kind of one
of those guys that you grab you think
he's going down he finds a way to wiggle
away from you a little bit and still get
the ball down the field it's gotta be
frustrating though that you give me your
best shot and oh yeah then you kind of
hear the crowd roar and you're like wait
he threw it you had no question it is
frustrating I know you're joining us on
behalf of Bellator tomorrow night it's a
MMA fight 163 on spike TV why don't you
get into MMA why first you know my I
think it was my second year two thousand
six I was training dhoni offseason just
doing MMA training I wanted to switch up
and do different things and working my
hand-eye coordination working my stamina
and I fell in love with the sport then I
came across and met met a few guys and
start training with other MMA guys
chocolate down I've been in it with
Randy Couture and all these guys I said
now I love this sport did you fight
against them no no we are not I wanted
to who did you want anybody but I'm glad
I didn't you wanted to Ladell and know
that i was i was very young and dumb oh
no that was something that didn't want
but being in it with those guys you
realize how tough it is as a sport as a
sport but I wanted to just get better
might in playing football and over time
we found a way to start to your med
Scott Coker
bellator and we found a way to get my
apparel company lights out involved in
Bellator so now you know Here I am
Thanks who would be good in the Octagon
NFL player yeah i would i would say a
lot of the top pass-rushers you know i
would look at like a tamba hali right or
Justin Houston someone who is uh just
great with their hands you know James
Harrison be good as big as he is yeah
but you know just the shortness it works
your disadvantage when you don't have
the long limbs and you're still you have
247 pounds JJ Watt JJ Watt would be good
I think he's just too big of a too big
of a person I looked kind of too much
room to hit you yeah absolutely so you
want to be wanted a piece of chuck
liddell yeah well at the time I did you
know but I was also very young and
that's smart so could you beat up all
four of my damage at the same time just
as long as your guys not naked running
all eaten on his uh silk upset so
Pauly's naked you won't then you won't
find him no no he'll he'll take that
bath it's my move alan yes yeah he gets
naked and then you can't beat him up
Shawne Merriman to former NFL linebacker
by the way 45 and a half sexes which he
had for your career in partnership with
MMA's Bellator Sean created his a new
apparel company it's called lights-out
brand.com the collection designed for
both men and women attended and designed
to motivate the consumer towards maximum
performance Sean also promoting tomorrow
night Bellator MMA fight 163 on spike TV
yeah I had Chuck Liddell on and I made
the mistake of saying he sort of looked
out of shape with that battery
commercial that he was doing oh you did
but but he wasn't in studio oh good
perfect yeah Randy Couture came in and I
don't know how old he was at the team's
overall looked like if he had to hurt
you he could he was going to hurt you oh
yeah that's that's one thing about those
guys mouth with Chuck and Randy not too
long ago and you always wonder if they
got that one hook it's still left in
them it doesn't matter where they can
find it out is if that that one hook is
still there to to come and get you what
do you make a Brock Lesnar um he's he's
an athlete I'm he's an athlete and he's
someone that kind of train
back in two ways of wrestler before yeah
but he transitioned into a sport but
someone that big and that letak but why
couldn't he play in the other film
because it's more than that you know you
got a bunch of monsters up there there's
just freakish ability to play football
and I see it I see a lot of guys who are
big and strong and I see them one of you
know get on the field and those muscles
just don't cooperate with some of the
things you got to do and it just doesn't
it didn't translate well what would
happen if Shaq put on football pant the
same same thing a future nose tackle
would you be bothered would you be
concerned with shock no well not
leverage not even leverage you got to
get down there first I mean you know
football is a leverage game and if you
can't get down there what about madron I
think no I think LeBron would have a
tight end yo and tight end or some kind
of wire receiver or something like that
we he's on the outside not taking a
bunch of hits you know we seen his
basketball players left and right I
played with the basketball players in
Antonio Gates and you know he's just a
basketball player still with cleats on
and you see him getting out of his cuts
and doing some of the routes it's
nothing different Russell Westbrook to
me would be fascinating as a dissolute
Lee yeah if I put him as a as a wide
receiver or a defensive back he's crazy
athletic Oh his point his A to point B
is is amazing and that's what Walt is
all burst and how fast can you get there
Deon talked about Bo Jackson and he said
you know Dean Dean goes I'm fast but he
said you know he baptized Dion so bonus
running left Dion came up and he said Bo
baptize me and he just basically said
I'll heal you put you on the ground and
he said Bo Jackson just took off he did
he did that's the same thing with you
now play with LT ladainian tomlinson and
uh you know his just his takeoff and the
way he getting it out of his cuts and
it's just it's amazing to watch those
guys every day in practice just perform
like that and it's that's when you know
you're on a different level yeah
Bellator it's on spike TV it's fight 163
tomorrow night he's Shawne Merriman his
company new apparel company is lights
out brand.com it's great to see you
thanks for
up and by Paul II would like to block
you if he could if you put on some
clothes I mean no no he's got clothes on
but I'll have mclovin is the quarterback
Pauly you got one more pass rush in you
oh you know I got it I got a couple wait
what was that about who's playing oh
you're the quarterback oh boy and I'm
Shawn rush past Paulie we got to get
some waivers in his side no no no now do
you ought to worry about my gosh we're
not afraid of a guy in a cardigan then
oh wow look I look nice huh wow it's got
it updated mr. Rogers well his
collection is called lights-out brand
calm we'll see if it lives up to that
coming up the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience